you know the video that's going
everywhere today is there at Disneyland
in Anaheim this family I think they're
all one family right fighting each other
yeah they all got into a fight together
[ __ ] did you see the video yep
it's great one guy hit a woman the guy
wouldn't stop hitting women the one so
so it ends up it's this whole family why
don't you pull up the video that Rob
sent you the downloaded video this whole
family is there and they're in toontown
at one point in the fight you can see
that you know in Disneyland
they made first of all like there's all
like the cartoon crooked houses like the
roof slanted and everything and you can
see at one point in the background you
know in Hollywood they've the big
Hollywood sign they did something like
that except it says toontown and the
letters look like clouds and while this
guy is like beating the [ __ ] out of some
out of what could be his sister some
woman you could just see toontown and
cloud letters in the background it's a
great ad for this thing it's great it's
perfect for Disneyland by the way
everybody talks about Disneyworld and
how nothing ever goes wrong in
Disneyworld in Disneyland apparently it
takes four minutes to break up a fight
between some guy and three chicks so
this isn't a California this is an
Anaheim yeah she's pretty - which one
one of the white okay so I've hit pause
for a second I just want to catch
everybody up to speed the man in the
pink shirt just screamed today I don't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] a larger woman I don't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] and started punching
her without the head and he just yelled
as Fred Barry yeah meanwhile she's in
front of a stroller with two young
children two little kids in a stroller
she does hit him first that looks like
yeah she slapped him first okay out of
it still yeah she slapped him and then
he beat her about the face is that fair
yep that's it that's what happened okay
and then the other guy whether it was
prior husband this guy put the kind the
red puts his fist up to hit the other
guy I don't know who they are yeah so
nan the guy in the pink we were talking
about in the office I think the theory
going around right now is that the woman
is the man in the pink sister and a man
in the white and we're tweeting out this
video for everybody to see
and the man in the white is the guy is
the sister's husband so I guess if it is
your family even as adults you can kick
the [ __ ] out of your sister in
Disneyland sure that's fine right yeah
okay now they're just kind of swinging
at each other they're not really doing
anything I get there oh right what was
that about so I mean they're just
hitting the women like they're they're
squaring off and then I and then the two
guys are squaring off and then another
woman who's part of this group comes
over and she goes guys you got to stop
and then the man and the white punches
are in the face
yeah he does this is Disneyland yeah
there's just two guys that are squaring
off but they won't hit each other they
just keep hitting the women there's
children there's a woman in a motorized
scooter what a mess
but I'll tell you this if I was at
Disneyland no matter what I had a fast
pass for no matter what ride I was
trying to get on quick as possible so I
could get on line for it and everything
I would stop everything I was doing I'd
say Jess hold up hold up right here if
little Edgar was with us as you watch
two and a half I go Edgar you need to
you need to be taught a few things here
let's let's watch what's going on here
I'm gonna explain this to you after it
happens but let's watch this yeah this
would be the attraction of the day for
me
the guy can't keep the I can't close the
distance no eyes much taller okay the
woman got off her motorized scooter the
two men are still squaring off but they
don't want to fight no they don't want
to fight they're not eager to fight it
away
look here's the thing when they're next
to a woman they don't even square up
they just start punching but when
they're next to each other they keep
squaring off and kind of avoid hitting
each other yeah she did hit him first
another yes she did but he that's what a
great screen shot that is then the man
and the pink he's very pissed off about
the whole thing
meanwhile there's a ton of horrified
people just looking on yeah it looks
like it's the dates the lunchtime parade
like they've cleared off the road for
this grand attraction at Disneyland and
the man in the pink is now walking over
to the woman in white who earlier if you
remember he beat about the face now I
think they're brother and sister
I believe that strap let's see what he's
gonna do okay starts please grab her
nobody is helping no like I guess
there's this whole thing going on I mean
would you want to get involved in that
you know but I mean like if five guys
run over and stop it I mean or a group
just stops it I don't mean that one guy
should go kick his ass but a whole group
of people but I'm saying as you join
that group honestly yeah it was a maybe
five or six guys but we don't they were
already on the ground okay stay there on
the ground man you get your hands off of
her yeah it's not about being tough it's
about like as a group there's so many
more people watching and nobody ever
feels like we can stop something well
watch two guys beat up one guy and 30
guys won't stop it that's that even
though it didn't actually happen that's
that kitty Genovese thing right yeah yes
or are the movie called the incident
which was Martin Sheen's first movie
which I've talked about a lot
Martin Sheen and Tony Musante play these
two guys on a train terrorizing a train
car and again it's 67 so you know that's
a little dated hey yo stop it but it's
these two guys being just [ __ ] to
everyone on the train car and no one on
the train Carl just band together and
stop it yeah you don't look around and
all the decent people around you and go
others way more of us way more of us
let's just all look at each other and
stop it you all you don't think of
yourself as a group you're just all
individual
that what am I gonna do yeah it's
somebody else will do somebody also take
care it's funny how on social media yeah
if you want to see the difference
between social media who we pretend to
be with little costumes we put on online
and who we are now on social media
everybody would be weighing in and
commenting and saying do this and
aggressive this guy's a bomb and if I
was there and yet they're all there and
nobody does a [ __ ] thing yeah where's
the white knights for the women they're
getting punched in the face by one of
them where are they we're not even beat
just just protect you though Matt we're
trying to calm the guy down yeah saying
fight the or about you know yeah but it
saves the kids from watching their
family kick the [ __ ] out of each other
at Disneyland yeah you want you if you
want to see the different social media
in real life watch this Disney video
yeah everybody watching it that's the
people that's what real life is well
they're probably tweeting about it as
sure oh I'm outraged this is terrible
what's going on in front of me what if I
was there and I was a father or
something and I saw the size of these
guys yeah I'm not gonna go over and get
involved
no no I'm nobody I don't to get punched
you remember to it like if the police
show up I don't want to have to now go
to no and the idea is that they're not
we're not any one individual but how do
you get all these dads three or four or
five guys just walk over like just
trying to calm the guy down and go stop
you can't hit this what is that he's
obviously not logical cuz he's punching
these poor women yes no he's actually
quite logical because he's not getting
in a fight with the guy he is only
punching the women he's not punching
this guy he's not even though the guy in
the white in him were just kind of doing
obligatory things he's spent he spent 30
seconds sizing up with the other dude in
the white and then he was like you know
what screw this and he walked over to
his sister grabbed her by the face and
punched her yeah you could have just
done that he's very calculating you see
in the background where it says to town
to be so happy yeah that's a dude town
all right well let's see the rest of
this
[Music]
kids are crying fight drunk they got his
shirt ripped his pink shirted rip the
janitors kind of being like hey guys I
was just sweeping up here but could you
stop okay
looks like it's all done they're saying
let's get out of here baracy okay now
the women are the women are fighting
this [ __ ] was a soccer flop that was the
woman who was on the motorized scooter
oh is it really it she's down now and
the [ __ ] same fat woman that hit the
other guy hit her yeah she's the problem
Theatre in his family she's soccer
flopped right down she put this lady
keeps hitting everybody the woman in the
white yes the woman in the white punched
the woman who got out of the motorized
scooter Betty that's mom mom she's so
weird looking at the sister punching the
mom I think so I say that makes sense we
don't know do we know who they are is
that is that really know but that's the
prevailing theory yes so what we're
theorizing we're just you know basing
this all and optical evidence is that
the woman who got punched his mama the
one that goes down yes yeah cuz she got
off her motorized scooter she tried to
break up her two daughters maybe
fighting each other I think brown shirt
is pink shirts girlfriend but he punched
her - no no white shirt white shirt Gaya
punched oh you're right so pink shirt
comedy of errors
yeah shirt guy is punching his sister
right his sister's husband who's
watching pink shirt guy punch his wife
who is pink shirt guy's sister right
husband is now punching pink shirt guy's
girlfriend one good turn deserves
another
Stooges pink shirt guys girlfriend is
fighting with pink shirt guy's sister as
jim says turnabout is fair play right a
lot you do pink shirt guys mother comes
over she says hey stop fighting and pink
shirt guys girlfriend punches mama and
mama flops down boy does she that was a
[ __ ]
that was a real soccer flop she fell
right down you know I'm gonna tell you
something I'm really glad I was at WWE
doing wrestling commentary last night in
Newark because I feel like it prepared
me yes to tell the story of the visual
of what's happening in front of us let
me see that again I want to watch this
all remixed with Jim Ross oh my god snow
gold here's the best part she's just
laying there looking for attention they
all run over to her oh my god the woman
who's fallen the guy in the yellow is
the best yeah oh my god he's got like a
little like a like a nutcracker hat on
and a t-shirt that looks like a
nutcracker coat and he's just watching
all this happen he can't believe it he's
befuddled looks like Louie Anderson
upset it really does he's got short
little blue shorts on he's dressed like
a child but he's clearly an adult and
he's just watching this family tear each
other apart awesome
yeah please let me see them get her up I
didn't see this far okay so a girlfriend
is picking up mama so it looks like
sister hit mama let's go okay okay cuz
she hit the mother he hit her really
hard yeah because she hit the mother
that time in her really already no
clapping although he's not punching you
slap you cuz she hit the mother right he
opened hand slapped her by the way he's
got a nice chain on he's probably doing
very well financially yeah he's a big
guy yes guy he's a guy on a phone with a
walker yeah well yeah he's sitting there
like I think it's to pick up garbage or
something or maybe it's a cane I don't
know what a [ __ ] is that one is but I
like yeah I like the Asian guy that's
behind them he's looking straight ahead
like nope don't see anything don't hear
anything I got business to attend to
Oh GZ slapping her Oh oh my god
now-now-now the sister is down on the
ground and the cat now people are
rushing over all this security no yeah I
don't know if that's security or if
that's just somebody oh yeah yeah it
looked like at that point I don't give a
final video okay it parts for a second I
was wondering I was wondering if he was
gonna be upset that this was on video
but as luck would have it he don't give
a [ __ ] about no vide there's so many of
them being shot who are still me this
good job they did great they got the
whole enchilada
they held a long ways oh yeah the one
guy just walked over and just really
well it's sometimes that's what I'm
talking about not going over and karate
kick and I'm just right
alright I took a there were a couple of
guy a few guys and they were all tough
you got doubt well what a couple of guys
walk over like look at the size of that
[ __ ] creature in the red shorts so
[ __ ] giant I would walk over behind
those guys like 30 seconds after hey
whoa whoa once they had settled down I
would like walk over behind him and put
my hand on one of their backs like yeah
guys come on
but you don't have to do anything
violent you can just sometimes when a
bunch of other guys come over it that
kind of breaks it up it just you realize
there's gonna be a big problem just
let's go back in I want to watch these
guys come over sisters on the ground
yeah she is oh god she felt ill sister
was sister yes she fell down Mama's up
and sister fell down after the guy after
her brother
open-hand slap I'm starting to side with
the guy in the red heart in the side
with him now he's the guy who keeps
kicking the [ __ ] out of this one yeah
but the sisters the problem she hit him
first and she hit the mother first come
on she's a [ __ ] wild woman maybe she
said I don't know what's going on but
she's hit this [ __ ] she's hitting
everyone first you know you know so you
shouldn't hit you shouldn't hit people
you know there's a kid you shouldn't hit
people you man should never hit a woman
no a woman should never hit the gate
yeah my bilborough's a [ __ ] brilliant
bit on that how a man should never hit a
woman
yeah there's never a reason to hit a
woman well and a woman should never hit
her own mom and knock on the ground yeah
that's I mean that's a can we put that
as a rule too yeah
okay see oh look at the mother phone do
you think she's playing it up a little
bit a little bit to stop everything a
little bit okay and now sister is
blaming her brother pink shirt guy oh my
god oh he hates her oh you use the
n-word yep
look at the size of that dude in the
[ __ ] red shorts oh yeah that's when
he was like I guess this is over huh
yeah that's done but you see he's not
that crazy he's not running over
punching the guy in the mouth course he
isn't
he's not that crazy I love the guy in
the red shorts because I'm hat he really
is wearing a bucket hat just like chef
from Apocalypse Now absolutely he's got
a bucket head on and he's got walking
shoes on he's this like tough guy who
really is just there to have a nice
vacation he's the type of guy who like
he just wants his family to have a good
- but you could see by his calves
he'd pick you up by the legs and he'd
[ __ ] break your neck against a wall
right he's like Charles Bronson all he
wants to do is just have a good time
just let him have his life and just
don't [ __ ] with him yeah he doesn't any
trouble but if there's trouble there's
gonna be trouble
okay sister is still on the ground after
the slap attack and by the way look at
this look there's a three year old I
would say maybe even a two year old two
or three year old sitting in the
electric scooter with nobody even
looking at him just by himself trying to
figure out what the hell world did I get
born into but this guy is getting right
in front of the guys he comes over right
we'll be gonna be plainclothes
plainclothes cop may be that large
security Disney security yeah really
dressed like maybe but he has no
security
plainclothes plainclothes okay you know
wait what's that a pilot's outfit is
very very clever
he doesn't have security on his shirt
because he's meant to blend in you know
it could also
that is I'm really stupid how come the
undercover officer doesn't have a police
baton right no brothers he doesn't even
have a business badge
he's undercover but by buying drugs you
[ __ ] there is also a possibility that
these guys figured out pretty quickly
that all the dude in the pink does is
beat up women he's not beating up any of
the men great point so he's like oh
they're going out he's not he's only
gonna yeah we just want to send the
women over cuz then we had all the women
just not men this poor kid look at him
just sitting up in the motorized scooter
that's you go to jail tonight
people say that until they're locked up
Yeah right whatever hat is we're more of
follow-up we only have two of those
which part - there is it but well it
ain't continued sit-down like I didn't
know there's a part oh yeah it's a nice
long one I mean what type of life to go
you know what we should do today we
should go to Disneyland and then somehow
by the time it's mid-afternoon the Sun
is high it can't be that late in the day
to go from I'm ready to go to Disneyland
- I'm ready to go to jail over the
course of maybe six hours yeah it's
they're probably getting drunk people
drink in only afternoon you think so
come on around all bunch of shitty kids
yeah you're cranky you're online I paid
attention to the kids the [ __ ] needs
this exactly looks awful poor kid is
just sitting there like uh I don't know
he's looking at me I just walk off and
ride some of these rides by myself are
you guys just gonna fight with each
other dead are you just gonna beat up
our aunt for the rest of the trip can I
can I go and get on Dumbo or something
it'd be great if you just took off in
the scooter Mama's panicking yeah
okay now he's going after the guy in the
white for his girlfriend okay
and he just goes and gets her right all
he just goes it
wait is that his [ __ ] I guess some yeah
I thought that was the white t-shirt
guy's [ __ ] I don't know why she's bit
no no no no because the white t-shirt
hit her before pink and brown her
together oh that's right that's right
but he's also he's upset at girl now no
he's he's upset at his girl now because
his girl knocked down mama yes
no his girl didn't afford one I know
Hawaii shirt lady did maybe sister
knocked down mama sister is not she's
aggressive she's aggressive too many
characters I know this is complicated
great it's like a Tarantino movie yeah
really is it really is honestly this is
good better than once upon a time in
Hollywood will be I think I want to see
that though it looks amazing but this is
pretty amazing too mine's been my own
life how so just stunts
[Laughter]
well that asian guy he's not moving he's
just standing there with his Walker in
the middle of the whole thing oh now
he's beating up a young girl oh man
that's closed fist what the [ __ ] and now
they're all jumping on the guy that's
his girlfriend right I don't know but he
is dry god he's beating up his own
girlfriend see this is what happens when
a bunch of guys jump in they stop it
yeah that's it that's what I'm talking
five guys jump in everybody grabs a limb
it's just beating up women yeah that's
what can we go back what made him hit
her you guys can we link these two
people if they could watch yeah yeah I
mean we sent the story we're sending
them out on Twitter oh yeah we video the
videos in the store yes my smile with us
what happened now she's yelling of
course I mean this video will be on the
news all day today so no it's been
already been on yeah yeah I was like the
top story yeah
it's Disneyland well his mother's still
sitting there on the ground no that's
his sister he seems okay with this woman
says something right there that's his
girlfriend I don't know are you sure the
other one's not his I don't know who it
is no the other one's his sister we
don't know who's who I think no I'm just
saying that they're all coworkers
what happens is he has just been
promoted and she's upset that she did
not get the promotion I see the woman
who's on the ground is the CEO who
actually favored her for the promotion
and not him that's a great still shot
right there yeah she's out yeah that's
his sister who hit their mama and and
that's his girl no on the ground oh yeah
go back like to say minutes because she
says something that sets him off right
and that's his girl yeah when the
gentleman in the red goes over to thee I
believe it is pink pink and he goes over
to what I believe is his [ __ ] I believe
that to be true
try show some respect no he says that he
does site that he's just quoting earlier
in the film the man has established with
the referent they woman is he's upset
with the other man in the white t-shirt
for quote hitting his [ __ ] okay so we
know her pronouns I'm sorry I believed
the man in the white t-shirt to be the
pink t-shirt man's brother-in-law and
he's upset with his brother-in-law
because he may have
his [ __ ] but then he goes over to the
girl to bring her back and he looks like
he's being cordial yes and he brings her
back and all the city turns around and
punches her in the face
she says something she I believed that
she does pop off at the mouth at some
point yes
[Music]
[Applause]
as I calm down oh you hit my mom okay
that's what happened he found out so
he's trying to he's trying to figure out
what happened that ain't his girlfriend
I don't think I don't know who she no I
believe that I believe that's his
girlfriend because it was the girlfriend
and the sister that were in a circle
with mama we were all trying to figure
out who knocked mama down we thought it
was the sister but I believe this
gentleman in the pink has just received
information that in fact it was his
[ __ ] that hit mama not his sister
immediately he regrets slapping the [ __ ]
out of his sister until she fell to the
ground and now realizes that the barrage
of violence YUM was intended for his
[ __ ] not his sister look because
because of the strikes that his momma
received it is Latino I literally
haven't this clue was less exciting than
this you know Colonel Mustard hit that
[ __ ] with a pipe
can you imagine whoever had to write
down the police report for this okay
could you expose what to explain exactly
what what when did this happen no I
thought you hit her
let me see crabs room brings her beg you
hit my mind throws the punch right and
this is ironic because one of his big
problems with his brother-in-law was
that his brother-in-law earlier had hit
his [ __ ] but now he appears to be
hitting his own [ __ ] because his [ __ ]
hit his mama he doesn't like when women
are hit but he likes hitting women oh
yeah yeah hi Roenick but I get it he
doles out revenge he's like John wick
yeah that's right I believe he has a he
slaps the other woman he's the John wick
of hitting with him he's hit all the
women in this video except for mamas oh
yeah the boogeyman it's women the guy is
still there with this Walker he's the
best the Asian guy he's like Zelig she
[ __ ] shows up nothing happened we
just trying to figure out what exactly
is going on
okay it really looks like he just
time-traveled right to that spot
Photoshop in there so we're at the point
now where discovery is that it was his
[ __ ] not his sister who he had
previously knocked down who knocked down
mama
only a minute earlier he's a little more
aggressive with his [ __ ] there was
definitely a closed fist for this punch
well yet cuz he feels a bit humiliated
because he knocked out his sister with
open slaps when in fact it was his [ __ ]
that should have gotten those slaps so
now it's gonna be several closed fists
plus I would assume that he and his
sister
yeah I've fought before in their life
you think so yeah that's that that's the
feeling that I get and I also bet that
like if his sister hit mom that would be
he he would get less angry because
they're family and she maybe that's
happened before yeah it's weird that
when he finds out that his [ __ ] did it
yeah right that's that's annoying yeah
it's not blood it's weird how willing he
is like how quickly the the physical
starts with women whereas when it's with
men there seems to be a lot of sizing up
a lot of who's gonna do what first but
when it's women he just starts swinging
you bet he does yeah well he's probably
on a hairline trigger with his [ __ ] I
mean something tells me this is probably
not the first you don't even have a good
relocation that's a shame they look good
together
they do look except when he's pummeling
her shouldn't be hitting mama she
shouldn't hit she shouldn't be hitting
mama that's true
this [ __ ] does got a fat ass she
certainly does I do understand why he
likes her yeah sure quite a hiney very
attractive woman yep except bruising to
the face and then someone tells her
tells him that she hit the mother
oh Jesus Christ punched her right in the
face oh just hammering Hayes hammer
fisting you know what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you have to meet a hit a woman in front
of a crowd like this like how like
meaning how used to doing that you must
be it just doesn't occur to you if
you're what a faux pas you're come I
don't want to argue with a girl in front
of people like can you imagine he's just
beating up a girl in front of a crowd
you think it would look bad if you were
hammer fisting your girlfriend in front
of a crowd of people in Disneyland it's
like [ __ ] mass Fidel aspirin he's
[ __ ] this guy is in a lot of trouble
he's pulling her by the hair
[Applause]
okay somebody's gotta try that there you
go he's laying on the ground now now
they're all around him and he's not
getting up now
he got choked down okay now see there's
a guy in a suit with an earpiece boy
they really are slow to responders new
Disneyland it's embarrassing how slow
they were I mean this is Six Flags level
what Disneyland was really was
performing on I would imagine that heads
are rolling today at Disney they
probably didn't think that anyone was
going to toontown anyway
toontown is not the greatest no it's not
the Roger Rabbit got blond hair how
awesome is that guy yeah he looks like a
blond version of the killer in No
Country for Old Men all right just watch
him buddy you you know what I'll bet it
was stupid
leaning on his iPad but it was you Jim
because that was that was that was your
bull you night scene yeah that was my
apology yeah an apology that's okay you
know what yes
now maybe that's a woman not a man yeah
that's a woman she's security yeah and
then now they're cops
well they've how many are finally their
final purity stinks at Disney Disneyland
whatever it is that's the message your
security sucks and you're right hit
pause for a second how many people are
gonna sit there and differentiate
watching this video the thing says
toontown in the back all anybody's gonna
say is that's Disney and people
associate Disney with Disney World
you're not gonna sit there and read
every word in the article to find out
well technically it's Disneyland in
Anaheim and Disney World right it's the
same [ __ ] [ __ ] those two parks are run
completely separately though but people
don't know that yeah I know Disney cuck
yeah I'd agree though would never happen
in Disney World I wouldn't know for the
record Disney World takes very good care
of their patron oh it wouldn't have in
there yeah do you like it it's fine is
it okay is it no near as big as the one
in well no this is more of a local park
than Disney World
it's just a park yeah well it's two
parks but you know Disney World is like
vacation destination okay let's go back
to the video I mean that's so stupid
okay we're not anymore okay
well now I'm gonna go over there I want
you though we can okay you keep talking
you're making me feel like you just hit
mama you hit my [ __ ]
you hit my mama well you can see till
this gentleman in the pink who it was
one level of reaction to you you hit my
[ __ ] it wasn't happy but mama mom on
the other and that was a whole nother
level I still don't know the
relationship I'm not sure that's it I
think we got it wait a said to the guy
in the white shirt
you hit my [ __ ] and was he talking to
the girl cuz he goes you hit my [ __ ]
was he talking Joe because he wasn't mad
at the girl at that point well I think I
hit her right yeah the girl might have
hit the guy in the white shirt had
earlier hit the girl in the the guy in
the white shirt had earlier hit the girl
in the brown shirt and that's what
started this whole you know ruckus okay
okay you're a reset right is certainly
good yeah sounds like go off to do you
guys talk to the office okay looks like
he's Mama's back at [ __ ] oh oh keep them
away Vlad you let them go next to each
other again whether there's no cops with
handcuffs and Disney who here's the
thing here pause there's me [ __ ]
snoke's here nobody gets arrested and
just no nobody's getting stuffed in
Disney nobody's getting arrested in
Disney nobody's nobody's dying in Disney
we take care of all let's get him off
the property
people get kicked out of Disney but
we're gonna get them all I guarantee you
everyone got arrested right outside the
park maybe oh yeah right off the
property no they didn't what we got
kicked out and that's it yep just go
back your your your your merry way
yep now that there's footage though
police are looking into it but Disney
saw good they don't even have cops to
arrest these guys for beating up women
and I mean they do but they just kicked
them out there's more outrage over the
the dude licking ice cream then there is
this guy who's just going around Disney
beating up every woman he can find does
that go for Disneyland as well that
nothing bad ever happens I mm-hmm yeah
underground cities and stuff to take
people out not a Disneyland I'm sure
they just walked him right to the door
goodbye bye-bye
I mean Disneyland lets you out right you
know I mean it it's smack in the middle
of Anaheim right you know how many times
you've been there Disneyland
just once Oh how many Disney World no I
don't know
take a guess take a guess six Disney
town yeah oh jeez hundreds yeah they
call Travis the Jeffrey Epstein of
Disney World I tell you I hope Nicky
gets caught in a [ __ ] epstein like
scandal alright let's finish this out
looks like they're being walked off of
course he does of course he does well
thank God peace has returned to toontown
there in toontown these poor kids they
just want to just want to have their
Disneyland trip that's all that isn't
they just want to have their Disney that
makes Disney look her end
very very very and the fact that they
don't arrest you like like you're well
they're not gonna arrest him in Disney
way and I get that but I mean but they
shouldn't they should arrest him right
out violent threat the fact that they
let them go home is crazy crazy crazy
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]